well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages time to see them what is
making the headlines with the associate
editor of the daily mirror kevin mcguire
and the consultant editor of the daily
mail andrew pearce welcome to both of
you here with us until just before
midnight front pages then let's start
with the telegraph uh russia's claim
that it has tested or test launched a
new intercontinental ballistic missile
is on the front of the telegraph it also
has a new photograph of the queen
released to mark her 96th birthday
the eye says tory rebels fear a backlash
due to the controversy surrounding boris
johnson's recent fine for breaking
lockdown rules
the guardian reports the prime
minister's bid to block an inquiry into
whether he misled parliament over
partygate has failed saying a motion has
instead been tabled to delay any probe
the mirror picking up on prince harry's
us interview and his dither on whether
or not he will join the royals for the
queen's jubilee celebrations in june
the metro leads with prince harry saying
he feels his mother princess diana
is watching over him and has helped him
cope with the split from the royal
family
and the financial times picking up on
the netflix story uh saying it lost
close to 40 percent of its market value
after a fallen subscribers
quick reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us still a few more to come in so
let's return then to kevin mcguire and
andrew pearce who are with us now um
andrew you kick this off then uh let's
start with the eye
tory rebels fear being burned by johnson
i thought that was electorally but it
seems to be uh just generally doesn't it
after the owen patterson lobbying
scandal um they say so to bring us up to
date yeah they've got themselves into
procedural sea draw um tears here the
government so um there was a
labor to tomorrow uh i think it's
bizarre they're doing it tomorrow
because the prime minister's in india
long arranged trip to india big trade
mission uh it was tabling a motion to
try to
ensure that the the the the standards
committee commons committee all party
committee chaired by lay brempe but with
the tory majority investigates whether
the prime minister misled the commons
when he said there were no parties or or
if there were any events no rules were
broken
so the government was going to try and
whip tory mps into voting against that
there was a bit of a backlash so they've
now tabled a motion which they've ins
they're instructing their mps tomorrow
to vote for which will effectively say
any vote on an inquiry by the commons uh
standards committee should be done
um after
the police have completed their work and
also after sue grey god remember her sue
gray
she was they were the two most famous
words in the english language for a
while weren't they sue when her report
long awaited comes out which we think
the latest rumor is could be first week
in june uh in which case that's when it
would be done now i don't think it makes
much difference really
i can see why for the prime minister he
doesn't want any inquiry before local
elections uh but it wouldn't be
completed before that that time anyway
uh and what he's trying to do is kick
the inquiry into the long grass for a
few more weeks
but the reason some mps got upset about
it sorry to go on about this
because it has unfortunate echoes of
owen patterson that same committee we're
talking about here the standards
committee found owen patterson a
cabinet minister guilty of egregious
breaches of the ministerial code in
lobbying uh government ministers in
return
for companies who he's being paid by uh
the
prime minister tried to auditory mps to
vote against that deal uh to try and uh
reset the commons against it all
backfired it was a horrible disaster 24
hours later the government had to
withdraw owen patterson resigned as an
mp by-election followed which the tories
should never have lost but did because
of the way they'd handled it so um it's
got an uncomfortable echo of our own
pattern but it's nothing like as bad
yeah and certainly uh a number of people
in number number ten may well think that
the owen patterson affair started the
decline in boris johnson's fortunes
hence the sort of the symbolism of that
uh the guardians picking up on this um
idea of a delay so to the times in fact
as well at the top um but is it a fair
um idea do you think to to delay this to
allow those investigations to continue
or just yet another delaying tactic
which has proved actually quite
successful for the prime minister kevin
yeah and anna you're right that the
prime minister's problems began in
november with the own paterson affair
when he got it completely wrong he tried
to get his uh old pal uh off the hook in
part because he supported brexit and it
backfired spectacularly and then the
party revelations uh started coming in
my own paper the daily mirror uh by my
colleague pippa and uh you know the
number ten just tried to stonewall and
deny it uh instead of putting his hand
up and admitting there had been mistakes
but there's no guarantee
after the police and sue grey of finish
and publish their reports that there
will be an inquiry because this is a
this is a block presented as a delay
by
uh downing street because they want well
it postponed
because as the guardian and the eye and
other papers point out there was a big
push back by some conservative mps how
many would vote against uh well it's
probably a small number but a larger
number were threatening to abstain
but there will be no guarantee at the
end of the period that there will be an
inquiry and i suspect number 10 then
would say well we've had the police
we've had sue grey why have another
inquiry and then they would attempt to
whip their mps to vote against it then
so i think the the the tone of the the
guardian uh story is wrong there because
it's uh it's almost as this is a climb
though it's not it's a it's a classic
tactic
it's a delaying tactic to block uh i
understand why if you're the prime
minister you would want to do that but i
don't think it's good for for parliament
i don't think it's valid i don't think
you need
to wait for the police to report and sue
grey to be published to have the inquiry
because these inquiries are held
effectively in private to take a lot of
evidence get a lot of documents and then
they report and the
commitment would be that the report
wouldn't come out until after the police
have finished and grey
has published so they wouldn't wouldn't
be prejudiced so no i like a classic
classic classic
block presented as a delay from number
10. and it may it may work for him
tomorrow it may it may get some wavering
conservative mps just to say well i can
postpone uh
taking a firm decision either way by
going with this tactic but it's quite
clear what they're doing
they might say it's clever politics i
know i might approve of it let's be
under no illusion it is a block
presented as a delay
well we're certainly keep a close eye on
the ins and outs of that in the comments
uh tomorrow the vote or votes and see
how they present themselves
uh the guardian in fact is one of the
newspapers that uh pick up on our next
story which is you know mario paul uh
the final days or the last hours this
ukrainian marine commander who we
managed to speak to at sky news as well
uh the enemy is outnumbering us ten to
one very very difficult days we'll see
if a deal is done to get civilians out
uh whether some sort of prison swap
which is very unusual uh but you've
picked up on the daily telegraph which
is
the testing of what this paper describes
as the world's deadliest weapon
um which is something for the the west
to take note of i mean this is
extraordinary as well isn't it andrew
yeah and it's it's a weapon that it's
nuclear capable that's the point and
this is
vladimir putin strutting his stuff again
on the international stage trying to
intimidate nato nato allies and say look
what i've got and don't forget i've got
the world's biggest nuclear arsenal and
i'm capable of using it i'm capable of
using it against ukraine and if anyone
atta any nato country thinks of
attacking russia that this could be this
could be the result uh it's the worst
sort of saber rattling by putin and even
though i think increasingly he is
deranged uh and uh his attempts to try
and uh insist for instance that the the
flagship of the russian fleet was um
brought down by um russia by russian
endeavors shows how mad he is but i
don't think he's lost his grip
completely but he would
would would trigger a nuclear
conflageration i just don't believe it
and i think the west will look at that
and know it's know exactly what it's all
about it's designed to intimidate and
cow uh zelensky again of course the hero
of ukraine but also to make some of
those uh more uh militant nato countries
who perhaps think we should be doing
more but that's the reason we're not
fighting russia is because he does have
that nuclear arsenal yes and some great
quotes in this article uh one from boris
johnson who said it was hard to see how
the ukrainians could negotiate with the
russian president he said how can you
negotiate with the crocodile when it's
got your leg in its jaws um and then
they also quote uh somebody from the
center for strategic and international
studies
that called this probably the most
destructive single weapon on earth the
missile believed to have a range of
about 11 000 miles and can deliver
between 10 and 15 nuclear warheads at
hypersonic speeds now how how has it
come to this that we need to start
firing weapons like this in in test mode
no doubt while a war is underway on
european soil kevin i mean this is you
know between twenty
yeah well there's a great there's a
great propaganda value for
for putin too uh both both at home and
abroad at home you say look
patriots rally round we're an incredibly
powerful nation and uh he is warning
other countries look uh we have nuclear
weapons and we could use them and he's
ramped this up all the way through great
fears in ukraine he would use a tactical
uh
uh battlefield nuclear
weapon but
i'm just hoping uh
he doesn't i'm just hoping it doesn't uh
it doesn't come to that but
it'll be a great tragedy if there's yet
another nuclear arms race uh triggered
by this and uh billions and billions
more pounds are spent around the world
and in countries to develop weapons of
mass uh destruction that could uh cause
mass slaughter and the ultimate war
crime of just killing
millions of innocent men women and and
children i mean this this war in ukraine
is absolutely
horrific and the the consequences uh are
very unpredictable and clearly dangerous
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me once again the
associate editor of the daily mirror
kevin mcguire and the consultant editor
of the daily mail andrew pearce
who to start with it probably should be
kevin but but you may not care i don't
know anyway it's prince harry um no okay
let's go to andrew let's go to you then
uh all of the papers are absolutely full
of it i have to say um various different
focuses uh daily mirror focuses on
whether he's coming for the jubilee
metro on diana the other papers
extremely critical uh give us your take
look prince harry um has this very nice
warm meeting with his grandmother who's
96 tomorrow uh a private meeting
it leaked out these things always do he
then rushes off to an american tv
station of course an american tv station
that's where he lives now that's who
makes all his money although he might
not be making quite as much from netflix
more about that later
and and he tells us first of all is he
he's his job is to protect her how is he
gonna do that from living in the united
states having only seen her once in
about two years didn't even bother to
turn up for his grandfather's memorial
service the husband of the queen for 73
years his own grandpa didn't bother to
turn up for it can't tell us if he's
going to turn up for the queen's jubilee
memorial the jubilee
events in june to mark her 70th
anniversary as queen an extraordinary
achievement and then he comes up with
these extraordinary things like his job
is to protect her from whom
which wicked person is he trying to
protect her from and he also wants to
make sure she's got the right people
around her well that's not him is it
because he's never here it is the most
bizarre weird interview
and it's very touching that he thinks
his mother diane is looking over him and
that's a very nice thing for him but
really this is going to do nothing
whatsoever to improve his relationship
with his father the future king with
camilla the future queen not least
because we know that books coming out in
a few months time in time for christmas
is the kiss and tell about the royal
family which will pour even more oil on
troubled waters so how is that going to
protect the queen who we associate loves
and cares so much about well in happier
pictures at the very least the queen is
all over the front pages this
photograph released for her birthday the
birthday portrait there is the the
guardian's take on it amidst her fell
ponies on the windsor estate a photo
taken by henry dalau
we're told the photographer who was
commissioned to take a similar official
portrait to mark her 90th birthday as
she heads to sandringham to celebrate so
we wish her indeed a very happy birthday
leaves you a minute to talk about
what's happened to netflix
i don't know
i'm just looking at that picture she's
the one in the middle isn't she because
her hair's the same color as this
honestly she's 96 and beloved by the
nation now is not the time
do you continue
yeah but yeah that's what you monica's
always saying there's about uh you know
a fifth or a quarter of us who are
republicans and might not have any
animus towards her as a person kevin
netflix leave it on netflix you got 30
seconds
so there we go
yeah
just freaking that's what you've got
time for
and it's going to have a new series of
the crown isn't it they're going to save
it 40 loss in share price but the big
boom days are over my subscription went
up a quid a month and i'm just thinking
well do i do i carry on with it too they
go they're going to lose subscribers
they've got competition now they can't
just keep bumping up their prices
they'll find they're gonna they're just
gonna
you know kill the golden goose
well this is uh about stock market uh or
it's stock market figure plunging uh as
it talked about uh the fact that it's
set to lose another two million uh who
will be uh leaving the streaming service
um a decade long reverse first time
they've they've gone down and certainly
uh last night we talked about the impact
of uh you know losing its market and
russia as well anyway we'll see you in a
moment won't we thank you both very much
indeed for now thank you